there's something missing in our
understanding of intelligence
intelligence isn't just
training
uh the way the neural network is
conceived right now is great and it's
lovely and it'll be better and we'll
argue forever but
you want to know wouldn't it be great if
i said look i know how to invent an
architecture and i can give it a soul
and what i mean by a soul
is some i know for
real that there is internal reference
as soon as i not fake internal reference
and if we could generate that mechanism
for internal reference that's why our
goal direction that's why you have to we
can do that
get that goal directing this you would
love that robot more than the one that's
just made to look like it does
because you'll have more fun with it
because you better generate
search other problems get more novelty
hell you'll be able to fall in love with
that robot for real but not the one
that's faking it
what about fake it till you make it
well i think a lot of people fall in
love with with um with with fake
humans yeah it's it's nice to it's nice
to fall in love with something that's
full of novelty yes i i you know i can
imagine all kinds of robots that i would
want to have a close relationship with
and i don't mean like sexual i mean like
intimacy
because but i just don't think that um
novelty generation is such a special
okay there's like mathematical novelty
or something like that and then there's
just humans being surprised and i think
we're easily surprised that's fine but
that's that but you don't think that's a
good deal no that's good i'm happy to be
surprised
um
but not globally surprised because
someone else but i really want i was why
i'm a scientist i really want to be
the first to be surprised about
something and the first thing in the
first in the universe to create that
novelty and to know for sure that that
novelty has never occurred anywhere else
that's a real buzz right that's a way to
really know that i i you have to have a
really big lookup team
right yeah you're never going to know
for sure right that's that's one of the
hard things about being
and scientists searching for this type
of novelty maybe that's why mathematics
mathematicians love
discovery but actually they are creating
and then when they create a new um
mathematical structure that they can
then they you can you can write code to
work out whether there's whether that
structure exists before that that's
almost why i would love to have been a
mathematician from that regard to invent
new math that really i know pretty much
for sure to not exist does not exist
anywhere else in the universe because so
contingent right but this gets into like
you are you said a few times but i still
really don't understand how you actually
plan to do this to build an experiment
that detects how the universe is
generating novelty or that time is the
mechanism
so the problem that we all have which i
think is what lex is pushing against is
if i built the experiment
you don't know what you put into it so
you don't know what
like if you unless you can quantify
everything you put in all of your agency
all the boundary conditions you don't
know if you somehow biased it in some
way so is the novelty actually intrinsic
to that experiment or to that robot or
is it something you gave it but you
didn't realize it's gonna be it's gonna
asymptote towards that right you're
never gonna know for sure but you can
start to take out you know you can use
good bayesian approaches and just keep
updating and updating and updating until
you point to one sensible purposes found
on how much novelty generation could be
yeah got it
so the ability generate novelty is
correlated with high assembly index with
assembly index yeah and yeah
because the space of possibilities is
bigger
so
um that's the key this could be a good
so a running joke of like why lex is
single this could be a good part for
uh so so what you're looking for
in a robot partner is ability to
generate novelty
and that's i suppose you would say it's
a good definition of intelligence too
boy is novelty a um
a fuzzy concept
is creativity better
yeah i mean it's that's all pretty fuzzy
it's kind of the same maybe that's why
aliens haven't come yet it's because
we're not creating enough novelty like
there's some kind of a hierarchy of
novelty in the universe well i think
novelties like things surprise you right
so it's a very passive thing but i guess
i would remember by saying creativity is
i think it's much more active like you
think there's like a mechanism
of like the things that exist are
generating the creativity novelty seems
to be there's some spontaneous
production it has it's completely
decoupled from the things that exist no
i i understand i i think that there's
it's really really creativity is the
mechanism and novelty is the observable
yeah
novelty could just be surprising your
model of the world was broken and and
not necessarily in a positive way that's
the prize so there's three things now
let's go back that's cool right let's go
you've got surprise which is basically
i'm i don't i mean i'm surprised all the
time because i don't read very much i'm
pretty dumb i was like oh wow
i often used to invent new scientific
you know ideas and i was really
surprised by that and then when looking
literature properly and it's there so
surprise that's to the extent that you
don't have full information um
creativity the act of pushing
on that um kind of on the causal
structure
and novelty which is measuring that
degree
right so i think that's pretty well
defined in that regard so you want your
robe i mean in the and in the end that's
why actually the way the internet and
the printing press share
some um i actually think creativity has
dropped a bit since it created since the
internet because everyone's just just
you know just regurgitating stuff but of
course now it's beginning to accelerate
again because everyone's using this tool
to be creative
and boom is exploding
so i think that's what happens when you
create these new technologies
that's really that's really helpful
there's a difference between novelty and
surprise okay i was i think i was
thinking about surprise
if you give me a toy that surprises me
for a bit it'd be great robot surprises
me you know experiment that surprises
you yeah i mean that's why i love doing
experiments because i'm i can't it's
still exciting yeah surprise is exciting
yeah
even negative surprise like some people
love drama and relationships like
it's like why the hell
why'd you do this
that could be exciting i could imagine
companies selling updates to their their
companion robots that just basically
generate negative surprise just to just
spice things up a bit yeah it's the push
and pull that's that's one of the
components of love as you said love is a
complicated thing
you